Katy Perry bumps up the release of her
new music video swish
[Music]
before Katie's so-called frenemy Taylor
Swift drops her highly anticipated
single from her just announced album
reputation on Thursday night Katy
surprised fans dropping the visuals for
her song swish-swish earlier than
expected on Thursday morning the song is
said to be about the pop stars feud I
think that this song just poses a
question in your mind she enlisted a VIP
roster for the basketball teams
including stranger things Gatson
Matarazzo Terry Crews and Game of
Thrones Thor
[Music]
meanwhile the 32 year old singer is
gearing up for her hosting duties at
Sunday's 2017 Video Music Awards and
rumor has it that tea slip and Katy
could share this stage together that's
not happening as far as we certainly
seeing all the rumors flying around but
no that's that's not happening
when et spoke to the executive producer
for this year's show
he played coy when asked whether Swift
may hit the stage for a solo performance
right now there's there's nothing
happening right now so there's you know
the we certainly are aware of all the
rumors flying around but wouldn't that
be great but now